OR 30 YEARS IN PRISON.
AINSLEY?
AINSLEY: OKAY.
THANK YOU, BRIAN.
THERE IS NEW RESEARCH FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
REVEALING THE HEAT AND HUMIDITY
AND SUNLIGHT FLIGHT A POWERFUL
IMPACT ON KILLING COVID-19.
>> OUR MOST STRIKING OBSERVATION
TO DATE IS THE POWERFUL EFFECT
THAT SOLAR LIGHT APPEARS TO HAVE
ON KILLING THE VIRUS BOTH
SURFACES AND IN THE AIR.
THE VIRUS IS DYING AT MUCH MORE
RAPID PACE JUST FROM EXPOSURE TO
HIGHER TEMPERATURES AND JUST
FROM EXPOSURE TO HUMIDITY.
THE VIRUS DIES THE QUICKEST IN
THE PRESENCE OF DIRECT SUNLIGHT
UNDER THESE CONDITIONS.
AINSLEY: WHAT DOES THIS MEAN AS
WE APPROACH THE WARMER WEATHER
THIS SNUREM HERE TO DISCUSS IS
FOX NEWS MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR
DR. MARC SIEGEL.
HEY, DR. SIEGEL.
>> GOOD MORNING, AINSLEY.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
AINSLEY: GOOD TO SEE YOU, TOO.
WHAT DO YOU GATHER NOW THAT YOU
HAVE HEARD THIS INFORMATION?
>> THIS IS GOOD NEWS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
THIS IS WHAT WE LOOK FOR AS THE
WEATHER WARMINGS.
WILL IS HUMIDITY IMPACTING THE
VIRUS?
IS HEAT AND IS SOLAR LIGHT?
THE CHART THEY SHOWED YESTERDAY
SHOWS THE VIRUS IS KILLED TWO
SECONDS ON SURFACES AND 1.5
SECONDS WHEN IN THE AIR.
THIS IS CONSISTENT, AINSLEY,
WITH THE SARS VIRUS IN 2003.
THE EXACT SAME THING.
AND THAT VIRUS, IF YOU RECALL,
ENDED UP DYING OUT.
NOW, THAT’S NO GUARANTEE HERE
THAT THIS WILL BE A SEASONAL
VIRUS.
BUT WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS FOR A LONG TIME HERE.
SO HAS DR. FAUCI, SO HAS
DR. REDFIELD OF THE CDC.
THEY TOLD ME THIS JUST LAST WEEK
THAT THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT THIS
MAY VERY WELL BE A SEASONAL
VIRUS.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
IT MEANS THAT YOU MAY STILL SEE
SOME CASES STRETCHING FORWARD
INTO JUNE BECAUSE IT’S A
PANDEMIC MEANING THAT THERE IS
NOT A LOT OF IMMUNITY TO SLOW IT
DOWN.
BUT THE SEASONS MAY SLOW IT DOWN
AND IT DOES SPREAD NEARLY AS
EFFECTIVELY WHEN IT GETS WARMER,
IT LOOKS LIKE.
AINSLEY: DR. SEALE THE VICE
PRESIDENT SAID YESTERDAY HE
THINKS IT’S LARGELY BEHIND NEWS
A MONTH MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND.
SO, IS THIS JUST A TIME FOR US
TO BREATHE AND THEN IT COMES
BACK IN THE WINTER?
ARE YOU -- WHAT ARE YOU HEARING
ABOUT THE VACCINES?
WILL WE HAVE ONE BY THE TIME THE
FLU COMES BACK AROUND AND COVID?
>> FIRST OF ALL, AINSLEY FIRST
QUESTION WE ARE LOOKING AT
AUSTRALIA, SOUTHERN HEMISPHERE,
ARGENTINA, LOOKING DOWN UNDER TO
SEE WHAT’S HAPPENING NOW.
WE ARE NOT SEEING A SURGE OF
CASES DOWN THERE.
REMEMBER, THEIR FALL IS STARTING
NOW.
YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENS IN
OUR FALL.
THAT’S WHAT WE DO WITH THE FLU
SEASONAL EVERY YEAR WE LOOK TO
THE FALL AND SOUTHERN HEMISPHERE
NOW TO SEE WHAT’S HAPPENING.
THERE IS NOT A SURGE OF CASES,
WHICH MAY BE WE HAVE TO WATCH
THIS OVER THE NEXT MONTH MAYBE
SHOWS WE WON’T HAVE A BIG SECOND
WAVE.
WE CERTAINLY HOPE.
SO IN THE MEANTIME WE ARE
LOOKING AT PERFECTING THESE
TREATMENTS.
WE ARE LOOKING AT DIFFERENT
ANTIVIRAL TREATMENTS, DIFFERENT
TARGETED THERAPIES.
WE ARE LOOKING AT REMEDIES VEER
WHICH CRITICAL CONDITION CALL
TRIALS ARE ABOUT TO COME OUT.
THE VARK SEEN BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
GO VERY CAREFULLY WITH THIS IS
STILL PROBABLY ABOUT A YEAR
AWAY.
HOPEFULLY THATS CAN HASTENED.
WE CAN’T BREATHE TOTALLY UNTIL
WE HAVE A VACCINE.
IF WE HAVE ALL THE ANTIBODY
TESTING WE NEED TO KNOW WHO IS
EXPOSED AND WHO IS IMMUNE, THAT
WILL HELP US LOOSEN RESTRICTIONS
AS WELL.
THAT’S SOMETHING THAT IS
STARTING TO BE RAMPED UP NOW.
I REALLY WANT TO SEE MORE AND
MORE TESTING ANTIBODY TESTING TO
SEE WHO IS IMMUNE.
AS WE WAIT FOR THE TREATMENTS TO
EMERGE.
AINSLEY: I KNOW.
I THINK WE ALL DO.